there's just so much that was left on
set
sorry man breakups are hard I just miss
her she called you back
she doesn't have opposable thumbs
hey is it cool if I sit here there's
like no other spots anywhere yeah well
I'm just I'm on my last canto are you
kidding me
well they're the only two people in Los
Angeles reading Dante I'm Mary Britney
nice to meet you it's not funny like it
says it is
hi oh one sec oh by the way this is my
dog Laura I have a dog yeah cool we
weren't always that into each other oh
[ __ ] I gotta get to work is you mind
watching Laura for a few hours
she's super-easy just like one walk okay
okay Sam are you voting for seemed like
a Sanders you don't like go for a walk
or just we can like go for a walk but
then something changed
we can't get enough of each other yeah
sure thank you okay girl okay
Britany what the [ __ ] mmm
what is that Laura yeah like it but then
things got really hard it's just it's
not working for me okay
Laura don't look at me like that get a
grip Brittany guess I'll go oh and you
[ __ ] in my shoe
real mature Laura real [ __ ] mature
but then came the drinking
and the jealousy who the [ __ ] is she
and that's what happened damn well you
know what they say to the world you may
be one person but to a doggie maybe the
world no time heals all wounds
oh no I haven't heard that one it's
pretty common phrase it's not one okay
baby
hey how are you what's it say I'm gonna
see you two even well I'm good
awesome cool how are you I'm good woah
woah hey Laura you look good I like this
collar light on Thanks
well good this anyway you should copy or
something similarly ah school yeah okay
then I found out about an offshore bank
account she had what the girlfriend for
her dog